yeah but well you know you haven't seen
the way I cut catch angles no I haven't
seen it and you haven't seen what
happened to I get hit and I have to dig
down deep cuz I when I dig down deep
yeah you got are you none of you guys in
this [ __ ] room has seen what happened
when I want to dig down deep and what I
do is I take both my hands yeah I make
palms I put my face in my hands and
fellow and I'm you cry nope I don't I go
see Uncle Buck no I lock bar which means
god is great
don't say occupy walk all right I don't
some difference not not I'm not moose as
that ice not a Muslim what I do is I
take my hands like this you're right to
think that I would be praying that way
yeah I put my face in my hands
yeah and I'm there ignited yeah I'm
inside my chest I go yeah I go you can
be somebody someday you can be somebody
better you better than Tom you're better
than Brendan I just say that because you
guys are there watching ridiculing me
yeah and then I pull my hands away yeah
then you punch yourself in the face and
and I run at him yeah I run out him with
my house a gym I do want to see you
fight I look into microlights I look at
my go you gonna have to kill me you
gonna kill me and then it's just body
never watch me die watching tired can we
fight for charity why you do a charity I
died as I die flip both you off and I
just yeah do you guys ever do a charity
thing like that would you ever if
someone came be one was like Tom Brian
listen not against each other but yeah
you know maybe you and Bert I mean look
I would scope out I think it's a if it's
for charity
I think like anybody right you look at
what what is the actual scenario what
are we looking at here let's say I put
on a charity fight night which we could
easily do right out yeah and I have you
and Bert is the main event my god that
would and all the charity goes to this
this kid's home I don't want hurt bird I
was about to say that my biggest issue
when like my trainer wants me to fight
Freddie Prinze jr. for a charity like a
you think you know her dangerous yeah I
will if I punch my face I'm not really I
mean if if this using me if I punch you
in the face I'm gonna hurt you if
Freddie box is way more than you do sir
no no you're a mom i box as much as he
does that's not true is that true you're
on the road
the time box as much as Freddie that's
not true hey we belong to the same gym I
know what I'm talking I just talk to
Freddie yesterday I know what I'm
talking about so can you just don't talk
don't talk out tough you when I talk no
what I'm saying is that it's not what I
was gonna say if you let me finish what
I'm saying is that he wants me to do a
boxing charity with Freddie right I like
Freddie Freddie's great guy
the problem with fight with doing that
yeah is that if it's a charity and
people are watching I'm really gonna
[ __ ] box yeah and I find it very
awkward when I spar yeah to even hit
somebody hard with a jab because it's
awkward yeah and you're hurting them so
when I get in there I have jabs somebody
man why don't we give you some what I do
hey dude you got in the room with me and
I gave you a headache and if the guys
pretty good I don't want to get hit I'm
gonna be trying to hit you back but you
guys it's for charity and you guys don't
have headgear on dude it's for charity
and also I mean doing it at whatever gym
do you go to club work yes would raise
$14 so but if you did it at the right
venue in the right charity not might
you're completely missing mine or not I
get what you're saying I'm telling you
if you guys did it once
trust me both you would be just fine
knock him out Bernard Hopkins I don't
know but wait oh I do know Brennan is
that I know this I know you think I'm
gonna come believe Buzzi oh I'm saying
I'm not saying you tell him beddy would
be fine well well or he wouldn't or I
wouldn't somebody's gonna somebody I've
gotten hit in the head not even that
like hard by a female boxer it [ __ ]
really hurts good yeah I don't think I'm
trying to say is that understand you're
not gonna go balls to the wall try
ripping Freddy's head on no otherwise
you're probably not the guy for the gig
right what I'm saying is that when
people get Andy Dickens but then as a
but when you're sparring and a lot of
people are watching I always feel like
it's gonna escalate like I always feel
like you're gonna get hit I guess what
I'm saying is that I would find it very
awkward I really wrestling jujitsu
somehow if ever were you yeah then you
would never do it but that's one could
get guys like Tom and Bert together you
could do it there's a ton of guys you
could do I think it'd be more fun for me
to not do it with Bertha so honestly
because you're so close yeah and it's
like you can say just body shots let's
say you're right you're right you could
but I'm saying let's say you're like
look I want to be able to just punch I
don't really want to
we're not saying that you know I would
devastate them but like I don't really
want to rock that you know I mean like I
don't want like to rock my however it's
charity guys who'd have headgear on 60s
gloves it's still hurts Brendan you're a
pro fighter
your mother [ __ ] hurts I don't know
maybe I'm seen with so many smokers I've
seen these charities before no everyone
walked away just fine I'd be more fun to
do someone I don't like we'd do that
yeah who do you not like to go down the
list so no the way I look at it as if
you're if you're even remotely athletic
and you've been and you you trained
enough right say you trained three days
a week
okay and then you shout out boxer you
can get to a point where you can
actually throw a right hand pretty hard
okay and it's not hard to hurt
somebody's head yeah and I you know I'm
telling you here's the other thing you
forget that like the less trained you
are let's say that's tree and I are in
the ring the less control you have over
oh I'm gonna do it this way and make
sure not to do that for sure instincts
are completely means the more exhausted
you get totally so after a minute yeah
everyone's me just fine that I'm Tony
Iommi's yeah you're right knowing your
rights but you guys no one's conditioned
enough you're right now we're going
again the other thing is is you could do
just your left hands so you get we tie
your right hands behind you that that's
funny but then it's even crazier or not
yeah for charity depends on the charity
you know I'm saying I'd have to be a
mascot you could be a mascot [ __ ] that's
he could be in the seminoles outfit
where'd you go to school
lenoir-rhyne who's the mascot bears
deers boom yeah come on that's a big
bear he's a Seminole yes I'm in
Lululemon I want to wear white I'm good
tight sick yeah you got nice tank top
yeah I'm oiled up she is for the right
charity would be fun I feel like no
matter what I'd throw a [ __ ] left
hook and then he'd be like I do stand up
through a straw now responsible for him
yeah when you see my back rippling I
pull myself up like a champ like a chimp
thirty times fast while talking to you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a gif it's a gift it's a gift